[Música]
el cairo está listo para el desfile
dorado del faraón los restos momificados
de 22 miembros de la antigua realeza
egipcia recorrerán las calles de la
capital este sábado las momias se
trasladan desde el museo egipcio en el
centro de el cairo al nuevo museo
nacional de la civilización egipcia
es un momento conmovedor al pensar que
tantos miembros de la realeza egipcia
atraviesan las calles de esta moderna
capital y de hecho regresan a una
antigua capital al fustat el primero en
la fila es sequen en 30 o segundo que
reinó sobre el sur de egipto en el año
1600 antes de cristo- el último carro
llevará a ramsés 9 que fue faraón en el
siglo 12 antes de cristo el
descubrimiento de las momias comenzó
cerca de la ciudad de luxor en 1881 y la
mayoría de ellas no han salido del museo
egipcio desde principios del siglo 20
esta excepcional procesión marcará la
inauguración de su nuevo hogar tras años
de construcción del museo nacional de la
civilización egipcia abrirá
finalmente sus puertas este sábado
egipto espera que este nuevo museo
contribuya a atraer el turismo un sector
muy afectado en el país desde la
revolución de 2011